une ville dans la ville à
Saint-Cyr-l'École sur l'ancienne emprise
de la caserne renard un projet de zone
d'aménagement sur 25 hectares dans
quelques années sortiront de terre 1500
logements un complexe sportif une maison
des associations et des jeunes un groupe
scolaire de ces classes et des commerces
les Saint-Cyriens sont invités à
participer depuis ce samedi à des
ateliers de réflexion Jeannette rousse
habite la résidence en face de la
caserne j'habite ton premier ange je
vous propose
inquiétude c'est au niveau de la
circulation au niveau maintenant
bon j'ai quand même je suis à la
retraite donc
j'ai plus d'enfants à garder c'est vrai
qu'il va y avoir des grands complexes
sportifs
crèche etc
circulation espaces verts équipement
public éducation tout ou presque est
passé en revue c'est toujours
intéressant de d'écouter de voir s'il y
a des choses que l'on peut encore
corriger apporter une contribution par
exemple sur des attentes qui vont avoir
pour des aires de jeux pour pour les
enfants la façon dont on circule dans ce
dans ce quartier au niveau de ce qu'on
appelle les modes douces donc on a eu
tout un tas de remarques ce matin puis
qui vont se poursuivre cet après-midi
lors du prochain atelier qui nous pour
nous permettre de finaliser le programme
et prendre en compte ses attentes
une trentaine de personnes pour ses
premiers ateliers le prochain aura lieu
le 13 avril et concernera les plans de
circulation et les accès un domaine où
les habitants auront forcément des
choses à dire